quantum computing의 중요성은 과소평가되기도 하고
동시에 엄청나게 과대평가되기도 해요.
기존 컴퓨터를 대체하진 않겠지만
quantum 혁신은 새로운 컴퓨팅 패러다임을 나타내요.
Quantum 컴퓨터는 현재 컴퓨팅 인프라와 함께
이전에는 비실용적이거나 불가능하다고 여겨졌던
복잡한 문제들을 해결할 수 있어요.
이건 패러다임을 바꿀 수 있어요.
예를 들어 큰 수를 소인수로 분해하는 어려움이
현대 암호학의 기반이에요.
현대 공개키-개인키 암호화에 사용되는 숫자 크기로는
이 계산을 수행하는 데
가장 빠른 기존 컴퓨터로도 300조 년이 넘게 걸려요.
Shor 알고리즘을 사용하는 대규모 quantum 컴퓨터라면
이 계산이 몇 초 만에 가능할 수도 있어요.
이런 복잡한 문제들은 모든 산업에 걸쳐 존재해요.
quantum computing의 잠재적 응용 분야는
방대해요.
Quantum 컴퓨터들은 이미 더 커지고
더 강력해지고 있어요,
더 복잡한 문제들을 해결하는 걸 목표로 하면서요.
2016년부터 IBM은 악보처럼 생긴 그래픽 인터페이스를 가진 웹사이트를 통해
quantum 컴퓨터를 일반에 공개했어요
악보처럼 보이는 인터페이스를 통해서요.
그리고 소프트웨어 개발 키트 Qiskit을 통해
사용자들이 quantum 컴퓨터를 프로그래밍할 수 있어요.
기업 내외부의 과학자들이
비슷한 포털을 통해 실험을 진행하고 있어요
유사한 포털을 통해서요. 화학과
머신러닝 문제에 대한 접근법을 탐구하면서
어떤 종류의 질문을 할 수 있는지
그리고 기술이 더 발전했을 때
어떻게 질문을 구성할지 파악하려고 하고 있어요. 지금이
비즈니스 리더들이 quantum을 준비할
적절한 시기예요. 이 근본적으로 새로운 기술을 실험하고
확장할 조건이 갖춰져 있어요.
이 변혁적인 변화의 최전선에 서려는
조직들은
경쟁 우위를 차지하게 될 거예요. 이 교육이
여러분의 quantum 여정을 시작할 준비를 해드릴 거예요!